oh my god that was the most amazing
thing
lapis confused with the villain yeah
that's the one thing I think everybody's
taken from this episode is that was
amazing though
Lance's confused with the villain what
wouldn't you be yeah clearly there's
nothing else in this episode they would
get any attention whatsoever um so uh so
what happened with garnet I missed that
part
ah nothing it's uh I like to see vanilla
episode I was running around with a
couple of gems and then next thing I
know garnets fighting somebody so yeah I
saw you get some cock yeah I mean it's
no biggie I mean really nobody that's
cool uh you know just be said and I'm
like some up um so then I'll go with you
if um you wanna go first you want me to
go first cuz I think we both have
disappointing things to say ah let's see
who wants to offend the fanbase first ah
okay go ahead
it's a good episode i every single
person on the planet Slyke and this is
the episode you're talking about write
this as far as I know okay cuz you were
talking to other people and you said
it's this episode right and they said
yes as far as I know yeah
there's like other surprises and twists
and stuff at this I will be so many
people's like this one in passivity my
god would you fear you'll shit yourself
as far as I know I feel bad if it's not
I but maybe there's everyone that I
clarified more episodes do we have to go
before we're caught up I think there's
like two more season so it could be uh
there's other ones but oh if this is the
episode everybody's talking about it's
fine it's fine
did it's good by Elliott's deserve it
like although I you know as pump with
the iron would have I would have thought
that there would be more like with the
amount of talk like what what is it it's
Ruby and uh
sapphire said it yeah Ruby and Sapphire
she was blue so sapphire um I you know I
got more out of pearl and rose and that
whole thing like when she was talking
about Rose then I did with this cuz
there there wasn't anything except for
they meet and yeah and then they kiss
and poof and big kiss that was nice I
just I don't know there was all this
like build-up I was really just like
expecting like because I'm assuming
that's what happens in this episode that
I'm supposed to be like her maker right
I mean is it okay I'll give I'll give my
disappointing thing now so you you start
alright so what I'm missing maybe I'm
missing something I don't know so when I
did um when everybody was saying do
Steven universe be logs it's like you're
not okay seemed interesting whatever and
then out of nowhere suddenly my Facebook
explodes with everybody saying you got
to do it this episode happened you got
it you got to do it like right now like
20 pose or something like that saying
you gotta do Stevie logs like right now
and so um Emma convinced I'm like okay
something big happened obviously and I
go to this um I go to a convention like
I say you know conventions are sort of
in the morning where I see like I just
don't Cartoon Network cuz that's only
thing on in the morning like Saturday
and Sunday morning and Steven universe's
on I'm like oh well this is probably
this is the show everyone's tell me so
you watch a little bit just get a
general idea and I see the return and
jailbreak back to back and I just like
oh that's probably the episode everybody
wanted me to see so I go and and
everyone comes up and they're like oh
it's really good there there's this one
episode that's like really really good
and I'm like is it the episode where we
find out about garnet and they go yeah
okay look Ellie yeah that's the one you
know and I'm like it's actually the
first episode I saw so they're what that
whole big reveal and what pisses me off
is that I'm wondering watching now you
know watching it from beginning through
and when we learned about fusions and
stuff like that I feel like a fucking
moron
didn't put together with the three eyes
especially one being a different color
that I didn't catch on that she was a
fusion the whole time because that's how
my mind when I was on that that's how my
mind would have thought like a way
people confuse I wonder if somebody else
is already a fusion know when they when
they grab the gist it was like oh that
one's beans it was like poof I'm like oh
it's garnet I gotta getta my RIA
like I don't know if I was supposed to
have some sort of I even know a fusion
was existed this line I found it more
cool that it was garnet I'm like oh
that's cool it's garnet but like the
fact that they're to the like two lovers
joining late i s for me like the whole
Pearl Rose thing kind of like gave that
kind of thing away too early for me cuz
I'm like I felt much more invested in
that than I did this but it's because I
I don't know Ruby I don't know sapphire
well no not here I know there there's no
real connection we don't literally met
them for a minute I will say in fairness
though and I'm not saying we're I'm not
saying it's badly as I said it's a
perfectly fine episode and it's a
perfectly cool plot point that but
that's just it for me I'm just like oh
that's a really cool plot point I'm not
like like you know this okay a couple of
things one with knowing them I get kind
of a fury row thing out of this we're
just seeing the two of them even for
that couple of seconds I felt like I got
him and I felt like I saw the
relationship I know why they got along
they're polar opposites they balance
each other out they sort of completed
each other they were definitely super in
love with each other even like the way
they're animated when they you know grab
eater and stuff I mean you feet again
you feel the Cassiar but it's all
minutes correct I are where like where
Rose and by the time they were revealing
things about rose and pearl you would
you felt like you knew a lot of what had
been going on in this but this also ties
into like the whole Cora and oh what's
her name I always forget my name I'll be
uh sorry yeah about the whole korrasami
korrasami yes that the whole korrasami
thing where it's like it's like yes with
this I feel it's done better here
because I feel much more than
relationship but I think it's about the
same impact of like oh that's cool yeah
I you know obviously I got I liked it I
liked it in Korra just cuz it was like a
giant kind of last middle finger to Nick
abut it but see that's my problem though
is that everyone sort of exploded oh
she's bi she's you know here's this
really big thing and it's like great I
didn't feel really tight that much into
the importance of the story or anything
like that so we're here I felt like in
talking about fusion talking about
identity talking about all these things
I'm going to tie in a little bit more
degree yeah but just a little bit more
like in here's that okay let me this way
I'm not saying it can't further tie in
like here's the thing when Cora did it
you were at the end of the show we're
still what was it's halfway now what's
been really I think this is like the end
of season one I think there's still like
two more seasons yeah so we're already
in tomorrow so I'm saying this can be
completely explored furthermore like I
mean you could get really in-depth in
the way that Cora just did not so I'm
not saying this is the end of the world
I'm just saying right now I'd say this
does it slightly better but I'm in about
the same point of where I'm just like oh
that's cool I think it's one of those
things - right like watching anime so
much it why I this sort of thing just as
a it's like I'm used to kind of seeing
this even an animated well I think
because it's it's a twist as a
legitimate legal I I think it's
something even if you put together it's
still a nice little twist on it and yo
in fact only one other American cartoon
has done it where while the main
characters is gay here's here's the
thing I feel like this is the beginning
of a story and therefore it's just I
just don't have an emotional can there's
like with pearl and Rose I felt like
they had been telling kind of that part
of it for a while now that I'm like Oh
makes more sense I was way more invested
right now it's cool and I'm like this is
cool
but I feel like this is the beginning of
a story like somehow we'll get hopefully
more with their backs
yeah I have to I mean but again seeing
those and that is that that is the
difference between this and carcass with
core that was the end of the story no
more to go from there unless they do
graphic novels or something here at
least I'm like okay this is a great
start but and the way was built up I
just
imagine that like honestly I would have
thought the one with rose and pearl
that's what they were talking about
initially I mean here's the thing I mean
what we want in Italy and then you said
no this isn't what they're talking about
I'm like really as far as I know the
couple of people I've talked to you know
I said I said everyone came to my
facebook saying this episode happened is
this that episode and the people I
talked to said yes it was so as far as I
know this is the one and seeing how
everybody exploded with um with Korra
and the ending of that that would be my
assumption too that this would be that
episode um but again what I really like
about it is that with those two uh the
Ruby and Sapphire you know again we've
only known for a couple seconds but yet
like you said man don't you want to see
more of that backstory oh I do attend
and and how they complete it like I
really want to see more that it'll be a
pop wait it's just I I just thought
there was gonna be more to like here's
the thing the fight and the song the
song was fun um I got a lot a bigger
battle not even just I want a bigger
battle it's just like you could have cut
out two minutes of that battle and give
us a more character development with
Ruby and Sapphire it's that I felt I
felt like they just kind of like and
their fuse together and then it's like
there's this big fight but I'm like I
didn't really get to know Ruby and
Sapphire my I felt like I got to again
it's we're in those few seconds I really
felt like I kind of got to know them you
know like just what they're like and why
they're together seven yeah that's a
it's a I got to know them enough they I
won't say if you're gonna do a fight not
that the animation was bad or didn't
look cool and stuff like that but for
how much they were building this up they
come down there wiped out like
immediately and then the other side's
kind of wiped out immediately
like a little too quick on it's like
haha well I'm back together well why
didn't that work before Oh cuz you
separate them okay whatever I want you
have that thing again whatever it just
felt like for all this building to me it
was over too quick yeah it was just a
fight like it wasn't a battle and I want
my thing is if it's just like well if
you're gonna have just a fight versus
more character development
on what is a popping that apparently
everybody flipped the fuck out over I
would have gone with more character
development with that and sacrificed a
minute or two off that yeah so again as
far as I know this is like the episode
um and again I'm with you it's it's neat
I want to see it explored more yeah and
I think the reason it got so much
attention is because a it is a twist and
B it's really the only art time outside
of korah
we've seen like a lesbian couple so i
all these stats like - yeah in in
American cartoons especially once
intended for kids uh so I think that's
kind of like the big thing around it I'm
kind of with you I'm like you know cool
again we're making progress it was
interesting it was a good twist no I
mean um but I'm saying I said you know
it's a great qua point it is not the
greatest scene ever in a cartoon then
let me be this way let me put you this
way
it could be if you develop this further
and really make it worth it as it stands
right now it's a great start to a story
but I'm just like oh I'm like it's just
a start to it yes yeah there's gonna be
the way they talk about thought this
would have been a whole episode like
knowing now in retrospect what I know
like the way everybody talked about I
thought this would have been a whole
back story in the same like that fucking
scene from V for Vendetta when she's
reading that past tale about the two
lesbian lovers I doesn't need something
like that like maybe not as dark but
like something that really took like a
good 10-15 minutes and explored this and
as it stands I'm like no that was just
that was just a cool plot point and yeah
I got to meet them and now that I met
them I want to see more but I know it to
me it is a lot like Korra everyone was
talking about this ending does oh my god
you have to see it and it's again it's
like cool neat I'm kinda with you though
I would like more suturing out of it but
that's not the show's fault that's just
the show had this twist and it sort of
took a step and great and you like you
say it's a fine episode there's nothing
really wrong with it I would have liked
either a bigger battle or more
development on the gesso just as in this
show I I made because I felt like
they've been building up to this kind of
thing yeah especially watching it on
Rose and I like
and you had best like talking about all
the identity issues in this event I look
by the way I love the the interesting
things the villain was saying about just
like I know what you are
it's like fusions are weak and this is
that it was like before like like here's
the thing to them I'm really wondering
now we have not seen any men now I mean
not one I'm assuming this is like a race
of Amazon you know that's what I'm
assuming - I don't think there's any men
if there are we haven't some and even
the gems I me if I'm right I mean like
Steven from what I understand was not
conceived from like sex cuz the gems
whatever may they can be they can't but
they keep that's not how they reproduce
so I think it's something where it's
like the idea of the two of them being
in love you know and then kissing and
all that stuff is not a big deal I think
the fusion is probably like a bigger
deal like you said it's like oh it's
what weak gems do to become more strong
you know it's like cheating in a sense
it's cheating to win a battle or
something um and hearing more and more
about this race you can kind of see that
like it is a you know is Cobra Kai mercy
is for the weak a strength strength what
else a that kind of metaphor aspect of
they're doing something that society
their society does not agree with or
whatever or at least the jerky aspects
of their society so yeah I I don't know
I I thought it was I thought it was
really good that I just adds a good
twist there's a good surprise and I
really do want to look internet hype
does though like yeah I know this might
try to avoid the hype and when people
kept trying to tell me things about the
show I'm like please don't
mmm-hmm so it's it's one of those things
where it's like cuz I mean now that it's
like we know I feel like I can talk with
you know certain people about cuz it it
seems like people really want to talk
about it and so but you can't give it
away cuz it's a twist and everything um
and at the same time I'm kind of like
maybe cuz I have to get further but I'm
like I don't know if there's a ton to
talk about it talking about that be
longers probably longest well there's
not yet that's my point
yeah I want to see them they're fusion
girls I'm like okay but we don't know
anything else apart from that that's why
it just like I said I think it's done
it's it's more interesting than a corn
ami or korrasami korrasami it's more
interesting than I said this so I
thought korrasami was a bigger shock but
that's just because a it seemed to come
out of nowhere and be I don't think they
I didn't think Nick had the balls to run
it you know okay I guess be a bigger
shock but doesn't tie into a story as
much as why I like this no it doesn't or
it doesn't tie in but um but no that's
why I like but I also respect you
because I just don't think Nick would
have let them get away with anything and
they were able to slip that in at the
last second and the part of me the
Addams Family part of me that just likes
pissing people off is just like hey but
I mean this one that was less awesome
they didn't as family they just went hey
there's more of a dub you think hey
tacos rule um it this one it just it
wasn't as much of a shock because yeah
as I said they it just felt like they
kept we're building up when they were
dropping hints here and there it seemed
like this show was something where that
could happen yeah you're as in Cora it
didn't tickle OD yeah it just did not
seem something that Nick whatever green
light which is why I liked it in Cory
even though I acknowledge it didn't
connect as much to the story but just it
was just such a fuck you that my love it
you know you got a water you got ever
wonder if the creator when that episode
of korra came out cuz she probably we
know she had to had this plan that their
fusion stuff like the uh not the crater
was a she Cora
no not cor um uses core I'm sorry Steven
universe it should show the video there
that that's Ave there effusion as well
um but you got wonder the creator Steven
universe was like when Cora came out she
was like friggin probably she already
had like this idea it's like oh they got
to it first damn it
when we doing so much better but
whatever Oh wasn't it ok you know what
killed it for me all the hype yeah I
know I did this trick would have been
just glorious to see without knowing it
and I would've been like oh that's cool
and I could watch it wondering where
they're gonna go with it without having
to sit here and talk about the
implications of it as it relates to coin
it well I will say this to watching this
show knowing that information going in
like remember the episode where Stephen
Conde fuse and what his guard to think
she's just they're going like this now
we kind of know yeah that's someone who
is a fusion has been you know together
doing that for a low point good point um
so it once you know or there's even time
it's like you know it's difficult to do
and guards it's not difficult for me you
know so in and on top of that we know
that when garnet and amethyst fuse
that's actually for people now now and
what I like about this episode is we're
finally at a point where we've gotten
pearl we've gotten stuff with amethyst
now we've got garnet we're at a point
where we can really expand in delve into
these characters backstories now we've
gone
yeah the pieces we need to do it yeah to
now really dive in I don't like it's
been very pearl heavy and amethyst got a
couple of us is too it's like now we can
go into garnet it was always the silent
one the strong side type um so and I'm
really interested to see where it goes
so it's it's not a disappointing episode
at all it's a really good episode it's
just everybody I think was kind of
wrecking it for me though like all this
build-up and hype that it you know I
probably would have just rather seen it
without knowing going in but yeah um
again infinite everyone I've talked to
says this is the episode maybe anywhere
well you better be after you just put me
through this no okay everyone I've
talked to uh said that so if there is
like another one that's an even bigger
shock like I've had like five or six
people confirm like this is the one that
everyone was probably talking to me
about on Facebook as everybody was
talking about it after it happened um
yeah so it was good I mean it is is it I
stand by what I said I won't like to be
right now in this moment having not seen
the rest of the show I'm more invested
in pearl and Rose than I am necessarily
in these two just because I don't know
much about them but I'm hoping that
they're gonna totally expand it you know
it's funny I actually I've invested
enough that I'm just like oh like I care
about them and stuff but I'm like that
for me was the more kind of interesting
story so far like they may give us more
backstory with garnet and I
you know that I'm hoping because that
would be cool I'm really legitimately
interested that's fine because I'm
actually more interested in promos more
for the attack opposite reason I really
felt seeing those two again like I just
kind of got it I got their personalities
I got what they were like and why they
fell in love and stuff like that where
with rose and pearl it's like I'd yeah I
still feel like there's more and I would
love to know it's but a lot more about
real inroads the one that didn't work we
know these two her hand yeah maybe
that's why but that's why there goes
more invested it's cuz these two that
maybe it's cuz these two seem happy and
this is that it's like but pearl and
Rose is like ooh that was drama like
these to see my right and happy and hey
that's great I'm more power to them so
well especially at their opposites - oh
my god that reminds me the one leg is
best garnet line ever cuz with lapis is
just like alright I'll fuse with you and
think think I'm in for a few seconds I
was like lame I thought maybe she was
gonna was gonna turn there for a second
and cuz I was like great now we're gonna
see a bunch of episodes with you know
this fusion and her being quasi evil
until she returns again and becomes good
that's my phone my side - yeah but but
when she drags her back into the ocean
this is like now we'll have on this
planet forever Wow
and that this is just like this silence
and garnets just like yikes that
literally was what I was gonna say it
was like is right like before she said
yikes I just went whoa well that's tough
too cuz lapis has been so much of her
life as a prisoner and then suddenly
it's like now I'm gonna sacrifice my
life to be even more of a prisoner
though don't do so I'm sure they will
but but I like that I think that shows
even more the sacrifice and the
dedication so kind of what we thought it
would be whereas Islands gotta say I
think it shows she's a glutton for
punishment at this point maybe this is
all she knows yeah I know that's true
like Stockholm Syndrome you know and I'm
starting to like it's like I'm used to
it you know it'll hurt you torture you
save the world okay
oh yeah it's it's you know what it is I
think she's like it's gonna hurt you
more that's gonna hurt me so this will
be fun so um yeah that's about it good
episode i'm i yeah no I got no problem
with bringing lesbians in the cartoon
so now gay men they stay out okay
that's the abomination that's a fusion
that cannot happen at all sorry it's my
trump showing top is Trump anti he's
anti everything which is assuming it's
um but ng that is a listen hair like
that you know he's gotta have some crazy
hair dress yeah you know he's trumping
up his toupee wig thing whatever it is I
was gonna say with the exception of
Arthur I know they have like it's like a
gay dad or something like that I'm not
sure but uh or maybe not maybe a gay her
dressing me like oh my god that hair
what is going on oh now that if I
thought I was just like no no don't sell
gay hairdresser yeah I know you and I I
take that back I don't want insult but
they do much better yeah um but yeah I'm
trying to think like are there any gay
male characters and kid shows outside of
Arthur the more I think about it I don't
know if there are or even like side
characters it's mostly written the the
eater or whatever that was like a big
thing like it either
like all right no edgy me that was women
too I don't know I didn't watch the show
I just matter that was like a big thing
that was like that game yeah you mean
the PBS show yeah yeah there's like
either a parent or somebody or group or
something I don't think they had show
premiered to I was like 13 I was it was
Arthur kids you know no you know what I
think it's the spin-off with the bunny
or I don't know I had to look it up and
I forget what it is I'm totally abusing
this PBS show that sure has a huge bow
um but I want some assholes will try to
boycott that show they'll be like no
show there we go yeah um but yeah I'm
not sure that is true it's like whenever
they do a gay character it's also you
know what I love it when they like and
in the korrasami thing they're like some
people just like we're gonna boycott
well of course ami that was the beauty
of that that was another reason what I
thought was such a fuck you by the time
it had come out you get done it's over
yeah love that love it didn't give
anybody any choice by Osamu people like
grab boycott this cartoon because I'm
like a bunch of grown-ass adults we
cought in cartoons really like this is
your life this is like it's almost as
pathetic is doing few logs on a cartoon
hahaha uh well I look at it this way we
get paid to watch cartoons or we boycott
cartoons for free who's the real idiot
you know like ours a little better yeah
so um that's about it
uh good episode yeah good episode I'm
with you I think it quite into the more
hype but yeah I do want to know more
about them but I think that's what and I
will say I would did I get into the hype
as much no but the best thing I could
say about this show is it leaves me
wanting more yeah so better to want more
and hopefully get more rather than have
everything just dumped on you all at
once they're like oh I'm good I can go
now yeah I like we're only at the end of
season 1 so it's like there's so many
more season so much more we can explore
with this uh this was just the first
season yeah I imagine what I gotta go
after that it's gonna be like a foursome
we'll see you at the foursome later whoo